ce verdict de culpabilité pour tentative
de meurtre a plutôt surpris le policier
et bien d'autres personnes fanatiques
est-ce qu'il ya déjà eu d'autres cas de
condamnation de ce genre par mille corps
policiers au canada
en fait ces lignes c'est excessivement
rare si on compile par exemple le nombre
de morts lors d'interventions policières
dans des situations vraiment très
différente pendant 27 ans regarder en
1900 entre 1988 et 2015 il y a eu 100
23-17 donc de personnes impliquées dans
les opérations policières
si on regarde maintenant les dossiers
qui ont mené vraiment à des accusations
qui ont été portées contre les policiers
en fait il y en a seulement dix pendant
ses 27 années là meurtre au second degré
donc meurtre non prémédité il ya eu six
cas homicide involontaire coupable
seulement quatre cas et quand on regarde
sur ces dix dossiers en fait il ya eu
cinq acquittements 3 abandon des
poursuites
un cas qui est encore en cours et
seulement une condamnation donc on le
voit c'est très très rare est ce qu a en
fait de forcier quasiment unique parce
que lui il était reconnu coupable donc
de tentative d'assassinât donc très rare
surtout si on compare avec ce qui se
passe aux etats unis
oui exactement elle est encore plus
criant comme exemple en fait on le
disait donc 123 cas au canada pendant 27
ans aux états unis entre 2005 et 2015 il
y a environ mille décès par an lors
d'interventions policières alors ça veut
dire que pendant dix ans il y en a eu
dix mille alors qu'est-ce qui a mené en
fait à des accusations portées contre
les policiers
il ya eu seulement 47 policiers qui ont
été accusés et le quart d'entre eux ont
été condamnés alors tout ceci s'explique
en partie parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
deux morts lors d'interventions
policières dans le cours normal des
choses il ya des cas de légitime défense
aussi mais il faut savoir qu aux
etats-unis dans ce genre d'accusations
d'abord avant d'en arriver là il ya un
grand jury qui va se prononcer sur la
pertinence ou non de porter des
accusations et souvent belles les
américains trouvent que parfois c'est
pas un petit peu trop favorable pour les
policiers ce type d'intervention là on
se rappelle d'ailleurs le cas de
ferguson au missouri l'an dernier mais
justement est-ce que c'est pas en train
de changer de changer très très
lentement mais quand même
oui et aux états unis ou même au canada
puisque de plus en plus il y a des
témoins qui
prennent des vidéos de ce qui se passe
dans des expressions dehors des extraits
vidéo il ya aussi des systèmes de
caméras de service public si vous voulez
et donc ça devient de plus en plus
facile pour bâtir des cas contre des
policiers qui effectivement aurait
commis des impairs dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions et le cas de forcir
bessin exemple où l'on avait des vidéos
sous plusieurs angles et donc ça
confirmait ce qui à ce qui s'est
réellement passé si ce qui a conduit
donc à la condamnation donc
effectivement c'est en train de changer
petit à petit donc les vidéos commencent
à jouer un rôle comme preuve à
conviction dans les cas pour les
policiers on l'a vu aussi aux états unis
bien sûr merci beaucoup frédéric entre
eux